at LexCorp industries
we believe in technology that unites us
where inspiration innovation
in imagination all come together to
create a greater tomorrow today
now Lex Corp is proud to announce Lex OS
the world's most private and secure
operating system engineered with the
protection you need in the freedom you
want
to celebrate please enjoy our free lex
Wi-Fi throughout this venue and visit
our LexCorp booth for your free portable
charging device Lex Corp and the new Lex
OS providing the safety and confidence
we need in an ever-changing world let's
build a better tomorrow today
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so first
viral trailer from Batman vs Superman
kind of weird but seems like they're
going in as Skynet type direction with
lexcorp's I'm gonna explain that first
then I'm gonna do my flash arrow Q&A so
there are a couple reasons for this
viral trailer one they're just trying to
market the film in an interesting way if
you remember the Dark Knight that
probably had one of the most successful
viral campaigns of all time it was a
video of Heath Ledger interrogating that
random person a year before the film
came out so batman v superman zack
snyder using Lex Corp in that same way
trying to make it seem like a very
modern Apple type company with with apps
going everywhere like this new operating
system they're releasing in free
charging devices everywhere I wonder if
that's gonna be a thing in the film
I don't think specifically what's going
on in this ad is going to be crucial to
what's going on in the film I think
it'll be related I think they just want
to give you an idea of what Lex Corp is
going to be like in the film versus
previous films as part of this viral
marketing there was like this fake ad
that Alexander Luthor jr. who's Jesse
Eisenberg's character wrote and it was
just kind of honoring the previous
achievements of his father Lex Luthor in
his contemporaries like Ted Kord so the
idea is is that the Lex Luthor of
previous films is actually Jesse
Eisenberg's version of Lex Luthor is his
father so that kind of explains why he's
so young and why Alexis corpse business
model is a little bit different from
previous versions of the company in the
comics and on the side it also lays some
groundwork like they're like laying
tracks for Brainiac to emerge in this
universe because he might not be the big
villain of this film but I think he'd be
a big Justice League villain when they
get to that movie the only thing that
I'm worried by is that this is gonna
turn into like a cross between Ultron
from Avengers age of Ultron in Skynet
from The Terminator movies where by Tony
Stark tries to create this new AI fuse
it with alien technology like you know
in this universe would be Kryptonian
technology and it turns into this
self-aware monster like what if Lex
Luthor tries to hack Kryptonian code and
it leads to Brainiac that is just wild
speculation it'd be like a vast
departure from Brainiac in the movies
but you know you know me you never know
we're starting to move within the
six-month window before the film comes
out so we should be seeing an actual
trailer dropped producer maybe closer to
the end of the month moving into flash
arrow Q&A territory
so the
actually some things that we learned
about flash and arrow you know like the
flashbacks as well as what's going on
with zoom so I tried to pick some of my
questions based around some of that
stuff just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the premieres yet first
question Alex Ramsay asks what if zoom
is Eddie Thawne from earth-2 so here's
the reason why I don't think that it's
Eddie because Rick cos net is gonna be a
series regular on another TV show he's
only gonna guest star on flash season 2
and I think it's gonna be like earth to
or flashbacks I don't think that they
would let the big villain of a season so
someone who's gonna be ever-present in
the narrative be a character that's only
gonna be around just briefly I think the
idea of Eddie will continue to be
important to their emotional arc but I
don't think that they would try to
include that twist
next question poke nerds s seems like
the flash is more popular in his city
than arrow ever was yeah I mean that's
that's just kind of Oliver's cross to
bear he you know at the end of the first
episode he had that big call to action
they're still gonna be going after him
Quentin who we now know is working with
hive is gonna be putting together an
anti vigilante task force just like he
had in season one it seems like damian
darhk-- is gonna tell him to put
together this task force and get rid of
all the heroes so they can do their
business
next question gen asks Barry's mother
has to be alive because Eddie is dead
well actually she still is dead at least
on earth one we don't know what's going
on on earth two yet that was the reason
the reverse-flash was so pissed off at
Barry when he came back through time I
gave you everything you ever wanted why
didn't you take it you know and then
they proceeded to try and kill each
other the risk of saving Barry's mother
was just too great that's why the other
version of the flash the other version
of Barry from the different time period
said don't don't do this don't save her
we can't do it next question cyber Dirk
asks why is Barry's father leaving town
is John Wesley Shipp involved on other
projects scheduling conflicts do you
think him leaving central city is just a
plot point well he kind of explained it
in his speech where he said you know how
can you grow how can you continue to
become the man you're supposed to be
with me still being here it's kind of a
meta statement john wesley shipp
previous version of the flash how can
this show push forward if we're always
looking at the classic version of the
flash TV show that's like the you know
the met a real-life example that in the
narrative of the show that is they want
to take that crutch
away from Barry his father's kind of an
emotional crutch for him you could also
look at it as the show telling us that
John Wesley Shipp will continue to guest
star like when he said I'll be here when
you need me but he's not gonna be there
every single week and if he's not gonna
be in prison there's no reason to go
back to iron Heights every week to have
those scenes with him so it's just the
show's way of dealing with that issue
now because it's like if he's at a
prison then why isn't he around all the
time so for people that are freaking out
don't worry he's totally gonna come back
and get star on the show again I don't
know how many times this season but he
will be back next question Sergio asks
do you think that Cisco will turn into
vibe anytime soon or maybe on a third
season well I mean if you're talking
about vibe with the costume like
full-blown Justice League superhero I
don't think we're gonna see a version of
that this season I think Cisco will have
his powers but they'll look just like
they did in the first episode where he
kind of flashes sideways it's the scene
where it seems like he's having a dream
sequence or a flashback he's actually
flashing to earth to where he sees the
conversation between atom smasher and
zoom he's just sensing the earth to
Timeline that's what he's picking up on
he's like an antenna for earth too right
now that's what his powers are gonna
look like this season what will probably
happen is he'll just slowly get better
at interpreting those visions next
question dizzi asks could you mention
that zoom hunter so Lamont does not
harness the Speed Force so I assume
you're talking about comic book hunter
zolomon in the comics hunter zolomon
become zoom because he has an accident
while he's on the cosmic treadmill he
doesn't get struck by lightning like
most flashes do like even the
reverse-flash gets struck by lightning
but hunter Zola Mons body exists out of
time so like he exists between the
spaces in time so instead of actually
like walking down the street moving
through three-dimensional space he
actually moves through four dimensional
space moves through time is it's kind of
weird visually it would kind of look
like the exact same thing so it totally
makes sense the TV show had changed that
he also wears a costume that looks
almost exactly like professor zoom evil
Bart Dawn's costume which is also why
the TV show has changed his look and why
he looks blue the actor that plays Jay
Garrick actually gave us a little bit
more information on zoom - he just did
an interview I'm gonna play the audio
right here real quick you had your
powers yes and now you don't
I don't how cheesed offer you about a
pretty cheesed off it's great yeah
actually zoom double my speed season one
ends there's sort of a rift in the sky
and I get pulled up into it just prior
to that my speed is stolen and so the
mission is to you know get my speed back
and then I need very to help mark so
what that does is just confirm that
transferring speed force is gonna be a
thing this season I take your speed
force milkshake and I drink it up so the
TV show version of zoom does use the
Speed Force but if you remember
transferring Speed Force like giving and
taking speed force between speedsters
kind of became a thing during the Wally
West era like the classic Wally West era
we'll have to wait to see what some of
the other changes they made are but but
essentially that's the change they made
to zoom from the comics I'm sure when
the episode airs I'll have to explain it
again it's it's totally ok there's
there's some big confusion between zoom
in the comics professor zoom in the
comics and zoom on the TV show
next question Nick asks do you think
that Ronnie Raymond is still alive
actually the producers answer this
question flat-out they said the version
of Ronnie that we saw in the flashback
in episode 1 is dead he died but robbie
amell will totally come back as a guest
star what that means is is that we'll
probably see flashbacks we'll probably
see earth to stuff happening we really
don't know yet it's too soon to tell for
now they're just gonna be developing the
Jay Jackson firestorm character next
question Ranen asks this is an arrow
question I think the damian darhk-- will
be the type of villain like fire lord
ozai and avatar they'll keep fighting
him without success until the last
episode of the season well I mean I'm
sure they'll score some small victories
but yeah until they find out what's
going on with his powers they won't be
able to beat him the really cool thing
about Fire Lord Ozai from Avatar is that
he was voiced by Mark Hamill who is the
trickster on the flash I mean he came
back during flash season 1 and reprised
his role from the classic series but he
is also coming back in season 2 Mark
Hamill's gonna be back as the trickster
next question superhero fan asks Diggle
is the name on the grave
Felicity be too obvious and Thea would
leave Oliver to be the only member of
the Queen family well all say you know
Diggle is a really solid theory because
the producer said that Diggle looked the
reason he didn't tell everyone else
about hive that
heard about hive is because he feels
really ashamed that he's been so
unsuccessful in solving his brother's
murder that's gonna be a big part of
diggle's arced this season trying to
find justice for his brother what
happened with him so even though it
seems like he's been a dick to Oliver
he's actually torn up inside because he
can't solve his brother's murder he
feels completely ineffectual and it
seems like things aren't going super hot
in the city especially with them not
being able to do anything about the
ghosts so Diggle is in a really bad
place this reaction from Oliver at the
grave seems totally appropriate for a
friend like that dying under bad
circumstances the tone of Barry's
reaction also seems appropriate to it
being tickle because he knows Diggle
he's kind of a friend but it's not like
someone he's been romantic with in the
past like felicity right now the top two
choices are Diggle and Quentin I would
say Diggle like slowly moved up the list
a little bit higher than Quentin though
so we'll say best odds right now or
Diggle but that could change next
question the snip over asks what do you
think the storylines of the flashbacks
are why is he going back to the island
well they actually explain that
mysticism is gonna be a big part of the
flashbacks so when Oliver has that scene
in the episode where he says I've seen
some stuff you know where he'd like he
doesn't explain to them what mysticism
means that's what the flashbacks were
gonna be for as for what that's gonna
look like we have absolutely no idea I
just it will be closer to what's going
on with Damien dark like Oliver will
start searching his memory for his time
on the island to learn things about
Damien dark and that's how they'll
thematically linked up congratulations
to the winners of this week's reverse
flash ring giveaway there's actually two
I mean it's a premiere so the devil
giveaway hugi king and Ally choc ski all
you have to do is just private message
me on the back end of my channel and we
can get your contact info I'll get you
guys that our gift certificates so you
can order those rings I'm just gonna
keep doing the ring as a giveaway it
seems like everybody's really excited
about that so I'll just I'll just keep
doing that
so next round will start whenever I post
my next flash video whenever I post my
episode 2 video there is gonna be a
legends of tomorrow New York Comic Con
panel later today so if there's footage
all totally post it but in the meantime
you can click here for the Game of
Thrones New York Comic Con panel and you
can click here for all my flash arrow
videos thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you